jurors have gone home for the weekend
after a second day of deliberations in
the fraud trial of president Trump's
former campaign chairman Paul mana for
Thursday jurors submitted questions to
the judge today it was the media with
questions correspondent Peter Doocy
joins us live outside the courthouse
again with what they asked judge Ellis
good evening Peter good evening Bret the
jury is now deliberated for more than 14
hours over a two-day span and they knew
there wasn't going to be a verdict today
because this afternoon they asked if
they could go home early and the judge
said yes judge T as Ellis today also
denied a request by a handful of media
outlets including the AP New York Times
and CNN to unseal the names of the
jurors before the end of the trial the
judge said he couldn't do that without
endangering their safety he then
revealed he's received threats that now
require him to travel with a US Marshals
detail
Ellis also said he was surprised by all
the attention on this trial which today
had the president's sympathetic ear I
think the whole manner for trial is very
sad when you look at what's going on
there I think it's a very sad day for
our country he happens to be a very good
person it didn't take long for word of
the president's comment to reach the man
afford defense team at their table and a
restaurant near the court where they
await updates with Manta Ford's wife
Kathleen any reaction to the president's
comments this morning great comments
mr. bad foot really appreciates the
support of President Trump
and he does I'm told that during
deliberations Paul Manafort is kept in a
small jail cell inside the courthouse
with no access to a TV or reading
material Brett back at it Monday Peters
thank you